on est en direct Jean Messia euh Jean
Messia donc ben il peut plus aller
pratiquement sur les plateau télé donc
quand vous allez faire maintenant ben je
sais pas je j'espère quand même que
l'État de droit restera un état du droit
et que ce qui est arbitraire péremptoire
ou trancier sera rapidement cassé par
les juridictions compétentes c'est là
j'ai fait un recours hiérarchique auprès
du CSA pour demander de revoir la
décision au regard d'un certain nombre
d'éléments que mon excellent avoc maître
Géral pendelon leur a donné par courrier
la semaine dernière et ben j'attends la
réponse et si c'est pas le cas bah on
ira au contentieux vous pouvez vous
renseigner pour savoir si Julien Dray
est décomté si Pierre Lelouche est
décomté si Karim Zerbi est décomté ils
ont été soit député soit dans des des
groupes politiques comme il travaille à
s news il travaille à s news comme
éditorcé Kim zbi pas décoméon ben alors
donc effectivement donc il y a un deux
poids de mesure donc je pense
qu'effectivement c'est une sorte de
traque idéologique VI dire pas déc par
ont aussi été encartés ils ont même été
élus non mais je c'est pour répondre à
on été députés qui parlait d'adhésion à
un parti politique voilà c'est pareil
donc il y a une vraie rupture du
principe d'égalité je rappelle un
principe à valeur constinelle pardon moi
j'ai du mal à comprendre que l'arcom
n'est pas motivé sa décision ah B je
vous je comprends pas écoutez j'ai
envoyé tous les éléments à l'équipe de
de Cyril qui pourront vous confirmer
alors il l'arcom dit rien bon vous êtes
vous êtes Radi
c'est une phrase laconique à partir du 8
novembre je vous prierai de de classer
Jean Messia àartenance de points divers
droite sans autre forme de procès c'est
une énorme connerie ce qu'on fait ce
qu'a fait l'arcom parce qu'avec votre
cannoc vous avez presque de TR voire 3
ans d'émission de télé là Conner pay pay
c'est vrai et je remercie sincèrement
et T ceux qui m des bon
nouvell
un grand merci à ceux qui me soutienent
mais en fait non mais plus la plus la
cagnotte monte plus un certain nombre de
personnes je vous aime trop qu'estce que
je l'homme ne vit pas seulement deain
j'ai une pas seulement de il voilà ex
juste si vous arrivez à récupérer votre
place du coup et que l'arom enlève sa
décision est-ce que vous allez rendre
l'argent non parce que j'ai de grandes
ambitions par ailleurs pour la France
dans
l'argent je vais faire des annonces en
ce sens prendant lESAIN
jours vous allez vous allez partir
peutêtre allez faire un parti non non
non non non non non non je vous dis la
politique c'est fini miam ça pas pour ça
qu'on pas
faire avis on va pas tarder à voir au
Moon
mi
dans
Pasir est-ce que vous serez transparent
sur l'utilisation de il fait ce qu'il
veut mais non il faitil vecheter des
costumes non non là pour l'instant je me
fais plutôt Toer un
short pardon excusez-moi le le ton
moralisateur de Gilles de Géraldine avec
jean- Messia sur l'argent mais on dirait
des conseillers dir des conseillers
Crédit Mutuel qui te tapent sur le doigt
parce que tu as découvert il fait ce qu'
veut son
arent mais j'ai pas dit le contraire il
fait ce qu'il veut de son argent et
deuxième chose deuxième argument Jean M
g tu dis qu'il a été encarté mais il a
été encarté dans plusieurs parties il a
été au RN ensuite il a été avec er
Zemour donc certes ce sont parti de
droite des partis différents ce sont des
partis différents si demain il est
encarté au Parti socialiste on déc Sonon
dans quel parti des jeun politiques
plusur ce qui montre bien que ce qui
dérange ce n'est pas le fait qu'il est
été encarté c'est le fond de ses propos
qui dérange et pour ça on veut le
sanctionner profondément la cagnotte
l'objectif c'était 10000 € pour les
procès on est à
68 il ça c'est très important parce
queobjectif 100 € vous savez moi
j'aurais adoré ne pas être dans cette
situation gnial j'aurais adoré
dire j'aurais adoré ne pas avoir à
demander si on m'avait pas emmerdé avec
des décisions à la noix j'aurais jamais
fait ça et continuer je pas faire la BAR
mon question il pe prendreose il peut
prendre qu l'oseille oui non mais je
suis un petit joueur par rapport à
vous 70000 Bou persones les prend ici
sur 2 ans incroyable sur un an je de
Doig avec 10 procès sur les fesses ça
m'étonnerait tu as des procès sur les
fesses ouis regard attends que je me
lève pour all voir non t'emmerde pas non
mais c'est une vaste hypocrisie je
trouve qu'ici il y a beaucoup de naïveté
vous savez très bien que Jean Messia
propage des idées qui sont des idées
d'extrême droite qui sont des idées
idenés la franceoumise SER le prier
à dans ce CASL faut que tu
comptabilises par il est en mission
politique pour Zemour il est en croisade
pour
Zemour Mo oh mais arrête
g donc pour moi ça doit être décomté je
suis désolé vous êtes le
représentant vousz déc pense en fait que
N coulant alors je je vais vous dire le
nœud coulant du système en réalité
autour de ma gorge il a commencé à se
serrer à partir de la cagnote faite pour
la famille du policier comme par hasard
quelques semaines après je reçois une
une convocation une plainte pour escer
en bande organisé non mais on est chez
les fous et ensuite donc sans aucun
fondement là là encore et ensuite je me
prends une qualification politique de
divers droites que je n'ai pas alors moi
je vais je vais dans ce caslà si si tout
si c'est open bar moi je vais porter
plainte contre l'arcom pour
discrimination raciale parce que je suis
immigré sur aucun fondement là encore
c'est des racistes si si tout est si on
peut tout dire sans fondement B allons-y
gment si c'est plus un état de droit par
rapport à la
plainte attention manque les boucles
d'oreilles fais gaffe il y a un morceau
de cerveau j'an par rapport à la plainte
concernant la cagnotte c'est pas à vous
de dire comme par hasard une plainte
sans aucun fondement c'est à la police
et la justice quand M non mais
coincidence causalité avouez que c'est
quand même assez le timing pour le moins
interrog que tu répondes à G tout à
l'heure parce que tu voulais lui
répondre il t'a coupé non je sais plus
ce que je disais c'est vous qui m'avez
coupé c'est pas lui mais je suis dis non
mais je sais plus j'ai perdu le filout
un truc sur si c avait été quelqu'un
d'autre que jeania Mo ah si c'était
ça va au niveau de la mémoire non c'est
pas ça mais je je suis pasé moi c'est
des débats on pourrait en parler pendant
des heures c'est vrai que si Jean Messia
a été partisan et propager les idées de
gauche d'extrême gauche et cetera tu
serais le premier à dire bravo voter
pour la cagnotte et puis ne décomtez pas
il parle au nom du peuple et C dès que
c'est pas tes idées toi il faut que tu à
ce pointl faut tout arrêter faut
censurer on cens sur Noël on sens sur
Jean Messia on sens sur tous ceux qui
sont pas d'accord avec toi mon
simplementre tu coupes les couilles de
jamais ça c'est pas bon oui Pablo Pablo
Vivien qui est intervenant sur BFM
suffisamment déconstruit pour appartenir
à LFI
Mme il est comptabilisé comme comme
intervenant et fill ou comme même divers
gauch tout vous avez pris 70 boules
combien la canot la monté ou pourquoi
pas arrêté à 10000 puisque l'objectif
c'était 100 mais c'est pas moi qui
décide
madame c'est vous qui allez c'est vous
qui allez comme ça à partir de quand de
carnaval pour dire
allez
quandarrêterr si les G don les G donoun
une amie attaquez pasoun attaquez
pasoun personne n'est obligé de donner
l'acte volontaire moi j'oblige personne
il y a des gens qui me soutiennent
moralement il y a même des gens qui
parfois donne des toutes petiteses 5 € 3
€ en me disant écoutez moi j'ai pas de
quoi finir le mois mais compte tenu de
la noblesse de votre combat je veux je
veux participer je veux être avec vous
alors je sais que ça vous emmerde mais
c'est la réalité il faudra faire avec
ouais
sinon achetez-vous ça on va voir le
sondage merci achzvous ça ah ouais bon
voilà non à 77 % merci jean- Messia
d'avoir été avec nous et vous êtes
maintenant un homme
riche ah ouichir